ce matin le haut commissaire au Plan
président du MoDem maire de Pau question
et réactions
au 01 45 24 7000 et sur l'application de
France Inter François Bayrou bonjour
bonjour et merci d'être à notre micro ce
matin trois semaines de pénurie
d'essence une grève
interprofessionnelle hier un 49-3
l'Assemblée nationale cet après-midi
comment en est-on arrivé là François
Bayrou
oh c'est très simple il y a deux
mouvements indépendants l'un de l'autre
le premier c'est que nous n'avons pas
obtenu la majorité absolue à l'Assemblée
nationale donc ça c'est l'explication
pour le 49.3 tout texte difficile
ne pouvant pas être adopté par les
oppositions en même temps que par la
majorité va entraîner ce mécanisme pensé
par la Constitution et qui après tout
n'est pas scandaleux en quoi que ce soit
c'est que
le gouvernement a les moyens de forcer
l'adoption d'un texte quand les
oppositions en réalité son accommode
le mouvement de blocage que nous
connaissons sur les carburants il a
quelque chose de profondément dérangeant
pour moi en tout cas c'est que des
catégories sociales très réduites en
nombre on parle de quelques dizaines de
grévistes
si
ce que vous dites vous les journalistes
et qui est plus étudié c'est quelques
dizaines de grévistes dans chaque
journalistes
90 d'autres donc
qui se saisissent de la situation
difficile de l'inquiétude générale du
problème énergétique pour y trouver des
atouts pour leur situation particulière
et ça je dois dire que pour pour un
citoyen
lambda pour moi en tout cas ça a quelque
chose de profondément dérangeant et
d'ailleurs il s'est passé dimanche et
hier quelque chose d'extrêmement simple
c'est que les Français
appelaient à soutenir ces mouvements à
manifester en masse à lancer des
mouvements
de grande ampleur révolutionnaires les
Français ne sont pas venues donc vous ne
croyez pas la grande contagion
au mouvement sociaux cet automne vous
pensez que ça va se calmer en fait que
c'est une poussée de fièvre
conjoncturelle je ne sens pas les choses
comme ça j'ai dit il y a déjà plusieurs
mois que je pensais qu'on entrait dans
une crise comme on en a pas connu depuis
la guerre et c'est une crise d'autant
plus difficile à saisir que ce n'est pas
une crise nationale
toutes les analyses que nous faisons
entre nous font comme si c'était une
crise française et ça n'est pas
spécifiquement ou pas seulement une
crise française c'est une crise
internationale de très grande ampleur et
de laquelle nous avons du mal à saisir
les racines pour les extirper mais tout
de même François Bayrou sur total en
France le gouvernement a-t-il le
sous-estimé minimiser ce qui s'y passait
à savoir une grève depuis trois semaines
a-t-il tardé tout simplement à prendre
en compte les revendications des
salariés dans une entreprise qui fait 19
milliards de profits depuis le début de
l'année est-ce qu'il aurait dû tout
simplement là encore mettre davantage la
pression sur totale pour que la
direction ouvre des négociations plus
rapidement
d'abord il y a eu des négociations
ouvertes que je sache moi je participe
pas de de cette mode qui vise à faire
d'une entreprise comme totale le bouc
émissaire absolu je ne sens pas ça comme
ça d'autant que le maire de Pau aurait
du mal à définir ça parce que pour vous
le savez c'est le centre névralgique
avec des milliers d'ingénieurs et
chercheurs de la recherche et de
l'exploration de ce grand groupe
en France c'est un groupe qui est une
chance pour la France est-ce que tout va
bien dans toutes les entreprises y
compris des très grandes sûrement pas il
y a sûrement des progrès considérables à
faire mais se saisir de l'outil comme
celui des raffineries et de
l'alimentation des stations services
pour obtenir des avantages salariaux ça
je trouve que ça n'est pas comment dire
il y a quelque chose qui n'est pas si
vite là-dedans il s'agit pas de faire on
entend le message est passé sur les
raffineries mais quand même il y a une
question des salaires qui se pose plus
largement en dehors des raffineries vous
pouvez contester ce qui se passe dans
les raffineries et la grève il y a quand
même la question oui tout en vous avez
raison il s'agit pas de faire de Total
le utile ou le bouc émissaire de
tout ce qui se passe et toutes les
crises ce serait rapide et caricaturales
mais tout de même qu'une entreprise
fasse 19 milliards de profits au
deuxième semestre distribue 2,6
milliards à ses actionnaires que sont
patrons s'augmente de 50% alors certes
il l'a dit hier c'était pour retrouver
le niveau de 2019 enfin ce niveau est à
6 millions est-ce qu'il n'y a pas un
problème d'inégalité ou un sentiment
d'injustice qui est là quand même qu'il
y a des problèmes avec les très gros
salaires des très grosses entreprises et
des questions et des très gros
bénéficiaires
est-ce qu'il y a un problème avec le
salaire des grands footballeurs est-ce
qu'il y a un problème avec le salaire
des très grand des chanteurs ou de très
grands artistes
qui profitent d'une guerre en Ukraine
pourra faire des super profits
en tout cas
l'idée qu'on va aller cibler des gens
qui ont des responsabilités
importantes pour les pour les désigner à
la vindicte populaire moi en tout cas je
ne veux pas y participer est-ce que les
salaires des grands patrons dans les
grandes entreprises sont ceux qu'on
aimerait dans un monde idéal plus plus
égalitaire je suis prêt à dire avec vous
que ça n'est pas le cas mais vous voyez
bien c'est la question
la vie personnelle vous voyez bien ce
que je veux dire le
on est dans un pays qui traverse un
moment comme il en a pas traversé depuis
très longtemps grave et inquiétant pour
toutes les familles et ce pays là il
mérite autre chose que le la
transformation en conflit général de
toutes les difficultés qu'on rencontre
après que les choses puissent être
améliorées dans les entreprises dans le
football dans le dans la chanson ou dans
le cinéma c'est tout à fait possible ce
sont des sommes qui sont hors de notre
capacité de compréhension alors pour
améliorer les choses votre groupe à
l'Assemblée le MoDem a fait voter avec
le soutien d'une vingtaine de députés
Renaissance un amendement sur les super
dividendes versées aux actionnaires
super dividendes super profit super
taxation à déclarer Bruno Le Maire qui
voit surtout là une supercherie vous lui
répondez quoi et est-ce une erreur pour
le gouvernement en termes de justice
fiscale de ne pas retenir cet amendement
d'abord le gouvernement est maître du
jeu donc il est libre de mettre ce qu'il
veut dans le 49.3 dans le texte soumis
au 49.3 quand ce texte va arriver et on
va pas faire sauter la majorité moi je
dis une chose simple c'est un pays qui a
besoin de justice et de signes de
justice et j'espère que le j'espère que
le gouvernement
est tout à fait consciente ça de quoi
s'agit-il alors il faut voir à quel
point
je vais vous dire dans une seconde des
choses beaucoup plus importantes encore
entendez-vous le signe de ce que vous
êtes en train de dire et donc
il s'agit de dire les actionnaires des
très grandes entreprises plus de 750
millions de chiffre d'affaires
lorsqu'il bénéficie d'une période comme
celle dans laquelle nous sommes avec des
super
profits c'est super profit donne lieu à
une taxe légèrement augmentée
légèrement augmentée
et là on va mettre 35 %, ça veut dire
quelques dizaines d'euros de plus par an
pour un portefeuille
classique
c'est-à-dire
un signe un symbole et je pense que le
gouvernement pourrait et d'ailleurs
Elisabeth borne a dit qu'elle était
prête à regarder pourrait s'il faut
réécrire le texte de manière que il y
ait pas d'effet
négatif pourquoi pas mais
que le gouvernement se trouve face à une
majorité qui propose des idées
pour donner des signes qui soient des
signes d'équilibre je pense que le
gouvernement aurait tort de penser qu'il
y en a quelque chose de négatif pour moi
vous comprenez que c'est pas tout à fait
un mot que j'accepte
donc si le gouvernement on a compris
pas vous seriez déçu oui je pense que je
pense qu'il a plusieurs séquences de
réflexion encore mais il y a dans cette
période et dans ce budget quelque chose
d'infiniment plus important c'est que
grâce à l'Union européenne on va créer
un une contribution sur les entreprises
les plus importantes notamment du monde
de l'énergie qui va rapporter à la
France
10 milliards d'euros
là on est dans quelques
c'est mille fois ou 10 000 fois plus
important que que cet amendement que
vous évoquez et c'est grâce à l'Union
européenne
ça se passe dans tous les pays en même
temps
et ça c'est précisément pour les super
profits des énergéticiens ceux qui vont
profiter de la crise énergétique pour
améliorer leur résultat cela sont
invités à contribuer et à contribuer
dans des proportions très importantes
puisqu'il s'agit de
dizaines de milliards à l'échelon
européen et de quelque chose comme 10
milliards au moins en France François
Bayrou dans ce contexte politique et
social tendu comment Emmanuel Macron
va-t-il faire voter sa réforme des
retraites dans quelques mois est-ce que
vous ne craignez pas un embrasement
généralisé
non parce que je pense que le que la
méthode qui a été choisie est une
méthode qui précisément s'appuie sur un
travail en amont des 7 ou 8 sujets
majeurs de la réforme des retraites et
ce travail en amont je le crois sérieux
je sais que notamment les organisations
syndicales y participent de manière
sérieuse pas toutes pas toutes ouais
mais vous savez bien ce que je crois je
crois qu'il y a dans la société
française un grand courant réformiste
qui est très important pour l'avenir et
ce grand courant là je pense qu'il
aurait été profondément déstabilisé si
on avait choisi une méthode plus
plus brutale ou plus inattendu et je
pense que le gouvernement a bien fait
Emmanuel Macron de ne pas le mettre dans
un amendement au PLFSS comme il y avait
pensé ou il l'avait suggéré c'est ça je
pense que cette analyse était une
analyse de l'analyse du président de la
République qui a conduit à cette
méthode là était juste
je crois que si les Français comprennent
exactement ce que je disais sur les
manifestations de et la grève de
dimanche et de mardi
si les cons civique les consciences des
citoyens comprennent ont en main les
éléments et je n'insisterai jamais à ces
je dis ça aussi au titre du plan et de
la refondation
des responsabilités qui m'ont été
confiées sur ce sujet j'insisterai
jamais assez pour qu'on partage avec
tout le monde les réalités le réel la
réforme des retraites elle n'est pas
faite pour le bon plaisir du
gouvernement
vous parlez du grand courant réformiste
la CFDT et Laurent Berger était à votre
micro la semaine dernière en disant nous
on veut bien discuter sur le chômage des
seniors sur la pénibilité mais le
décalage de l'âge légal c'est niet et ce
sera mienne
je ne crois pas qu'on soit dans des
impasses qu'on soit devant une impasse
si on l'est il y a suffisamment
d'esprits chagrin et pessimistes qui
depuis le début ont dit vous n'y
arriverez jamais moi je crois que les
Himalayas sont faits pour être gravis il
y a
à faire cette réforme des retraites sans
trop de manifestations trop de grève
trop dehors c'est ce que je pense si on
est dans une démarche
d'absolu bonne foi pourquoi ça se fait
pas dans le cas du Conseil national de
la
refondationnel de la refondation
qu'est-ce que c'est d'abord peut-être
vous rappeler ce que c'est vrai qu'on a
encore pardon du mal à comprendre à quoi
ça sert je pense que beaucoup de gens
parfois parce que vous avez compris
comme c'est un c'est une méthode ouverte
il y a évidemment beaucoup de gens qui
qui parfois ont du mal à saisir
ça n'est pas une démarche
gouvernementale
institutionnelle
c'est le l'intuition que le Président de
la République a eu depuis longtemps
depuis le grand débat qu'il y avait des
problèmes sur lesquels on avait besoin
de renouveler la démarche et notamment
en s'appuyant sur ceux qui sont sur le
terrain ceux qui vivent les difficultés
mais justement les retraites par exemple
ce serait pas un exemple type pour le
CNR c'est à peu près ce qui est en train
de se faire dans les négociations
simplement ça n'est pas dans le cadre
qui a été défini
puisque le président avait dit ce
problème là on va le traiter dans une
négociation mais tout ce qu'on pourrait
faire pour améliorer la compréhension
par ceux qui vivent les difficultés
des nécessités et des obligations que
l'on a par exemple de faire une réforme
irad pour moi dans le bon sens quand
Edward Philippe engage le gouvernement à
bouger beaucoup sur les retraites avec
un report de l'âge de départ à 65 voire
67 ans vous réagissez comment vous savez
bien que je ne que ce n'est pas mon
approche pourquoi parce que à 67 ans il
y a des femmes et des hommes qui sont
usés je suis maire je sais ce que c'est
un CCAS
l'organisme communal qui s'occupe de
l'action sociale je sais qui sont ceux
et celles plus souvent celles qui
travaillent qui ont besoin je sais pas
si vous imaginez ce que c'est que de
lever des une personne âgée qui pèse 90
kg lorsque vous avez des problèmes
squelettiques et musculaire et que
lorsque vous arrivez à un certain âge il
n'est pas vrai que vous soyez aussi
valide que nécessaire la vérité c'est
que si on faisait ça un très grand
nombre de ceux qui relèveraient de ce
déplacement de l'âge de la retraite
serait soit en arrêt maladie payé par la
sécu soit au chômage payé par lesquels
c'est impensable
il y a beaucoup de gens qui seraient
prêts à travailler plus longtemps
notamment s'ils aient trouvé quelques
avantages je suis pour une politique
d'incitation je sais qu'il faut que plus
de Français qui travaillent plus
longtemps parce que il suffit de
regarder les chiffres entre les actifs
et ceux qui sont à la retraite
c'est celui dans l'idéal dans l'idéal
c'est celui que choisit chacun des
travailleurs il y a des familles
recomposées
parce que le premier qui a présent qui a
proposé la retraite à points lors de
l'élection présidentielle de 2002 déjà
celle qui l'a poussé également c'est la
CFDT vous n'avez pas réussi à cette
réforme élastique et qui devait être
plus juste et plus exceptionnel
une fois deux fois cinq fois qu'il ne
faudra pas un jour que cette réforme
soit repensée et s'applique parce que la
souplesse nécessaire pour que au terme
d'une carrière vous décidiez de
prolonger votre temps de travail et de
trouver peut-être d'autres
responsabilités dans votre travail on
est la précisément dans le modèle de
société qui va falloir construire c'est
pas une réforme budgétaire seulement
c'est une réforme qui est aussi un
modèle de société alors Nicolas est au
standard d'Inter bonjour et bienvenue
oui bonjour ma question est simple je
voudrais demander à François Bayrou pour
se voyou vous avez été nommé il y a deux
ans au commissaire au Plan avant le
commissaire au Plan c'était le plus haut
fonctionnaire de l'État qui était en
charge de la planification économique
aujourd'hui on parle beaucoup de
planification écologique ma question est
simple quel est votre bilan sur deux ans
on a l'impression qu'il est plus ou
moins inexistant et on aimerait donc
savoir ce que vous avez fait depuis deux
ans en tant que au commissaire au Plan
merci Nicolas pour cette question
beaucoup d'auditeurs posent la même
nous avons Adam le Commissariat au Plan
aujourd'hui c'est 5 personnes
nous avons édité 12
et 13 bientôt études stratégie sur tous
les grands problèmes et vous les avez
entendu tout ça alors je veux les
rappeler l'essentiel on a fait une étude
sur la démographie avec une proposition
stratégique sur la démographie on a fait
une étude sur la dette avec une
proposition stratégique qu'on a fait une
étude sur l'électricité qui a réhabilité
le nucléaires et qui a je crois
contribué y compris à ce micro a changé
beaucoup
l'approche que que les que les pouvoirs
publics avaient du nucléaire qui était
plutôt sur sur un changement
d'orientation et on a vu à cause de
cette étude ou grâce à cette étude où
dans cette étude que c'était
indispensable qui avait pas d'autres
solutions y compris pour le renouvelable
et nous avons sorti cette semaine une
note stratégique sur une des solutions
disponibles dont on ne se sert pas
aujourd'hui sur la géothermie de surface
c'est-à-dire la possibilité de récupérer
des calories de l'énergie immédiatement
sous nos pieds par des forages qui fera
que on économisera à peu près 80% de
l'électricité nécessaire pour chauffer
une maison et 90% de la même énergie
nécessaire pour rafraîchir une maison
parce que nous croyons qu'il y a un
monde de solution qui ne sont pas
explorés et peut-être ça permet de
renouer avec un avec un certain
optimisme qui est trop depuis trop
longtemps abandonné question piquante de
Frédéric sur l'application Macron énerve
beaucoup de monde mais ne commence-t-il
pas à vous énerver vous aussi non
je vais essayer de dire les choses
précisément
c'est une personnalité qui a des
aptitudes et des qualités et des
intuitions et une volonté de faire
bouger les choses qui est hors du commun
j'ai pas souvent de l'admiration pour je
vois vos sourires j'ai pas souvent de
l'admiration pour mes contemporains il
se trouve que cet homme là ce jeune
homme là parce que c'est un homme jeune
à des aptitudes pour cette fonction des
qualités pour cette fonction et un souci
de cette fonction je n'ai pas souvent
rencontré vous parlez de ces aptitudes
et de ses qualités mais quelle est sa
vision François Bayrou quelle sera sa
vision de ce deuxième quinquennat Macron
II ce sera quoi quels sont ces marqueurs
les marqueurs de ce deuxième quinquennat
parce que
on a du mal parfois à les voir depuis la
réélection il y a une forme de
flottement dans la vision
sans pensent et ressent quand je parle
avec lui c'est-à-dire assez souvent
notre modèle
est condamné à changer profondément
ajoutons notre modèle qui était en
réalité construit sur une capacité à
apporter à toutes les questions ou à
faire semblant d'apporter à toutes les
questions une réponse en termes d'argent
public
vous savez que c'est une question sur
laquelle je m'interroge depuis très
longtemps le déficit et la dette on est
aujourd'hui
au point où on ne peut plus
ignorer cette question
pas le constat ce qu'il va faire pas un
constat définir le nouveau modèle
français qu'est-ce que la France a comme
projet de société et qu'est-ce qu'elle
peut apporter au monde parce que c'est
un pays qui a besoin d'universalisme ça
c'est la première chose deuxièmement
réconcilier j'allais dire recoudre
les
les Français comme citoyens comme peuple
avec les pouvoirs il y a une rupture
entre pouvoirs et citoyens qui est pour
moi quelque chose de
profondément inquiétant en tout cas et
troisième marqueur puisque vous m'en
demandez trois
que on puisse trouver un moyen de vivre
ensemble sans que tout débouche sur des
conflits des affrontements des guerres
de clan qui soit irrémédiable ce qu'on a
absolument sous les yeux tout se
transforme en affrontement et en conflit
or une société comme la nôtre avec le
modèle qu'elle porte ne peut pas vivre
dans les années et les décennies qui
viennent s'en trouver un moyen que nous
puissions
décider agir ensemble marcher ensemble
sans être tout le temps à faire la
guerre aux voisins notre on a entendu
les trois mar la manière dont nous
avançons aujourd'hui c'est la guerre de
tous contre tous et je pense qu'il faut
sortir de la guerre de tout ce qu'on
trouve
pour savoir si la réussite ou pas
peut-être peut-être dans les quatre ans
vous aurez une réinvitation mais pour le
bilan ce sera dans 4 ans merci François
Bayrou au commissaire au Plan président
du MoDem maire de Pau d'avoir été à
notre micro ce matin il est 8h